anti-pipeline activists in North Dakota
could face arrest today if they don't
move out of their protest camp work on
the Dakota access pipeline is nearing
completion the nearly 4 billion dollar
project will carry oil from the Dakotas
to Illinois protesters are concerned
about potential damage to the
environment and Native American cultural
sites Omar Villafranca is near the
encampment in cannonball North Dakota
where a new showdown is looming Omar
good morning good morning the US Army
Corps of Engineers say they will not
extend today's deadline and some here
who oppose the pipeline's completion say
they will not leave but officials have
made it clear today's mandatory
evacuation order will be enforced this
is the main contractor access and with
us is where the protest first started
law enforcement here in Morgan County
North Dakota are trying to avoid a
confrontation that's been simmering for
weeks what do you expect to happen when
the deadline comes well they need to
leave I mean that's that's what we
expect to happen do do I actually
believe that they will pick up and leave
right on right on the 22nd no I don't
we're going to enforce fully remove on
our own land the camp population is now
on the hundreds down from the estimated
ten thousand only a few months ago when
confrontations with police sometimes
turned violent they're protesting the
completion of the Dakota access pipeline
which will run deep below a section of
the Missouri River they say it threatens
their drinking water and will disrupt
sacred Native American sites we've asked
for extensions and they were denied
chase iron eyes is an activist attorney
who has been camped out near the
Standing Rock Sioux Reservation this is
a forcible removal it amounts to an
ethnic cleansing it's a place that
Native Nations have the internationally
recognized right to be the Dakota access
last month president Trump signed an
executive action expediting the
completion of the pipeline North
Dakota's Republican governor Doug burgum
says he understands the protesters
concerns but president Trump's message
is clear what do you think will happen
when the dead light comes do you think
they're going to leave peacefully we
respect people's right to protest we
respect our our neighbors and citizens
that are you know enrolled members the
Standing Rock Sioux chod but what we've
got now is we have people that are
obstructing our ability to conduct a
cleanup in a flood plain of pollution
that's been left behind and that's
something that I think all of us you
know understand that that that can't
happen chase iron eyes told us that
before the deadline some protesters plan
to retreat to the other side of the
Cannonball River two camps that are not
on federal land Gail thank you very much
Omar